everyone telling me that I couldn't sell
somewhere online was the worst advice
I've ever heard my dad told me to go to
law school and I did if you want loyalty
buy a dog as the resident is a very see
a professor once told me never ask why
don't listen to anybody around you you
know you have to create the whole vision
by yourself
wacky stuff like that it doesn't make a
lot of sense the worst piece of advice
I've ever gotten is to go with what's
trying true the worst advice I've ever
gotten is that you shouldn't start a
venture fund I don't know I had a dance
teacher back in the day who told me
never leave the house without heels on
and I believe that it when I was 12 or
13 I don't think that's good advice
[Music]